the population is continue the growth
around the globe and also the
environment the climate is changing each
year so agricultural production it's
really challenged to meet the demand of
food and other agriculture product I
think there's only way to meet this
demand that is strengthen agriculture
results
Paulo technology can be used to improve
crops for ever-changing environment
particularly for the drought stress that
we were facing almost globally drought
is a much bigger issue than flooding
drought is also a more complicated issue
than flooding in terms of their
biological control there are modern
biology now is ready to take this more
complicated issue we should promote the
effort in using modern biotechnology to
solve this bigger problem which is
drought if successful the farmers in the
developing countries will be benefit
enormously
you